et on parle à présent de ces assises de
la cyber sécurité qui se déroulait ce
matin la Ferme du Manet à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux une journée
organisée par l'opérateur scène et
Yvelines numérique et qui avait pour
objectif de sensibiliser les acteurs
publics sur les risques cyber on en
parle avec notre invité à Stéphane blanc
qui est directeur fondateur président
fondateur dans tes médailles aussi avec
vous Nicolas dandry de la rédaction de
TV 78 et des assises qui sont tenus dans
un contexte particulier on peut le dire
parce que dernièrement plusieurs
collectivités il y a aussi des hôpitaux
et notamment dans les Yvelines qui ont
été victimes de pirates informatiques un
chiffre Grégory une trentaine d'attaque
alors c'est pas un chiffre officiel
c'est un chiffre de l'association déclic
qui a fait un recensement à partir des
informations récoltées une veille sur la
presse locale voilà des cyberattaques
sont souvent traités par la presse
locale elle a fait une veille donc 30
attaques en Île-de-France depuis 2019
dont 5 dans le département des Yvelines
et ça c'est on parle de la fonction
publique vous avez parlé des
collectivités des hôpitaux la fonction
publique française alors l'enjeu de
cybersécurité par rapport à la fonction
publique et bien c'est un enjeu de
souveraineté puisque quand vous parlez
de fonction publique c'est nos données
ce sont les données personnelles des
habitants ce sont les cantines ce sont
la gestion des
territoires et donc par exemple 3 dates
septembre 2022 la mairie des Mureaux a
été attaquée décembre 2022 l'attaque de
l'hôpital André Mignot de Versailles qui
a été totalement paralysé il y a encore
des conséquences en cours actuellement
et puis dernière en date c'était en mai
dernier la mairie de jussiers une
attaque pro russe voilà la guerre
dépasse même les frontières et va même
jusqu'à l'impression que ça se multiplie
se multiplier alors on va revenir sur
une des attaques à défrayer la chronique
un sel de Houilles avec le maire et on
écoute tout de suite Julien Chambon le
maire de la ville de Houilles
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus concevoir
nos investissements informatiques sans
la couche cyberprotection c'est
indispensable donc ça va vous comporter
à la fois des solutions techniques et
technologiques firewall système donc
pour repérer les virus en direct sur les
postes de travail et aussi l'aspect
humain ça veut dire que aujourd'hui on
travaille avec les agents de la
collectivité pour les sensibiliser et
faire en sorte qu'il soit aussi
partenaire de la sécurité du quotidien
en terme informatique de pas cliquer sur
un lien donc très régulièrement il y a
des pièges qui leur sont envoyés à
travers des mails notamment on voit le
taux de clic et on retravaille avec les
équipes derrière pour dire attention
vous avez pas fait attention à ça
comment est-ce qu'on fait attention à un
email qui a l'air qui a l'air
vraisemblablement authentique mais en
fait qui ne l'est pas et qui est un
piège tout simplement pour capter une
donnée importer un logiciel malveillant
dans votre système informatique votre
téléphone ou votre ordinateur donc il y
a tout ce travail et humain et
technologique qu'il faut faire en même
temps
Stéphane blonde et cyberata qui se
multiplient c'est une réalité ou
finalement peut-être juste une
impression qui est mise en avant un peu
plus par les médias dernièrement parce
que on a une multiplication dernièrement
vous parlez collectivités locales
collectivités territoriale vous mettez
pas en face effectivement les ETI les
PME les grands groupes non c'est c'est
en croissance bien évidemment la
situation
on est en face de nous
des gens dans ce métier c'est le job
voilà plutôt que de braquer des banques
c'est plus facile aujourd'hui que de
braquer à travers la cybercriminalité
les systèmes d'information de toutes les
entreprises et des collectivités locales
ou territoriales ou les hôpitaux de
l'Europe voilà qui est une cible qui est
une cible vulnérable bien sûr bien sûr
avec qui rapporte
les données Vous demandez des rançons
voilà le business est monté
c'est c'est ce sont des très belles
entreprises qui ont pignon sur rue qu'on
connaît qui sont sur le Dark voilà vous
pouvez bien évidemment vous faire même
enrôler par eux on vous propose des
logiciels
c'est assez étonnant oui je sais bien
c'est un peu surprenant c'est un peu
surprenant
c'est vrai que c'est ça peut être
surprenant Nicolas ouais effectivement
et puis vous l'avez dit les assises du
département ça sert vraiment à
sensibiliser alors jusqu'à maintenant
j'ai parlé des communes de Houilles de
Juziers juger ces 3000 habitants et des
Mureaux où il y a les Mureaux c'est
quand même des grosses villes mais ça
touche aussi les zones rurales et on va
parler notamment de la ville de
mitainville c'est une toute petite
commune dans le sud-yvelines de 650
habitants et ça y est la mère de cette
commune a pris conscience que la
cybersécurité ça peut aussi concerner sa
commune nous n'étions pas dans une dans
une inquiétude haute de des
cyberattaques parce que nous sommes une
toute petite commune et à tort on a
peut-être effectivement l'impression que
ne craint pas grand chose en tout cas on
a mis les moyens en ce qui concerne
toutes nos sauvegardes avec un avec une
société d'informatique qui vient faire
régulièrement nos maintenance c'est vrai
que la notion de moyens humains et de
budget va aussi se poser voilà donc oui
oui effectivement moi ma présence ici
c'est vraiment de de Me sensibiliser
d'abord et ensuite de pouvoir aller
solliciter les bons acteurs
alors dans cette interview Stéphane
blanc on entend parler de matériel on
entend parler le mot humain aussi c'est
important c'est aussi important en fait
la technologie est aussi importante que
l'humain parce qu'aujourd'hui la plupart
des cyberattaques c'est la cause c'est
l'humain déjà la complexité c'est bien
de recruter et encore plus dans la
collectivités locales territoriales dans
les hôpitaux nous à la rigueur on est
des industriels c'est notre métier de
recruter des gens d'un niveau et d'une
compétences et puis vous vous rendez
compte que les systèmes se complexifient
donc la nécessité d'avoir plusieurs
compétences est une problématique nous
on cherche bien évidemment à y répondre
à répondre à ces enjeux de compétences
puis il y a des métiers qui sont pas
intéressants enfin prenez le backup
voilà qui pour moi est un élément
stratégique c'est vraiment un des points
focus dans tes bêta c'est bien de de le
secours du système d'information c'est
la convergence de la sécurité on parle
souvent de cybers on parle rarement de
secours sauf que si vous n'avez pas le
secours si vous n'avez pas le backup
pour plan de reprise d'activité c'est le
dernier rempart c'est le dernier
remparts qui doit être opérationnel pour
redémarrer un système d'information et
ça c'est stratégique j'ai trouvé des
gens qui ont envie de faire du backup ça
n'intéresse personne juste pour
vulgariser le backup c'est pour noter
les spectateurs notamment le backup
c'est l'action vous avez alors bien
évidemment individuellement sur vos PC
j'espère en tout cas bien évidemment
mais dans l'entreprise c'est bien de
sauvegarder son système d'information
et puis derrière c'est testé ces
sauvegardes parce que vous pouvez
sauvegarder si vous le testez pas et
puis il faut penser métier vous ne
sauvegardez pas
vous devez sauvegarder dans un concept
métier parce que quand vous devez
restaurer vous devez restaurer un métier
et quel métier vous resterez en premier
et alors ces métiers là et ben les gens
n'aiment pas et alors du coup vous
imaginez j'ai conçu même un mot moi pour
ça j'ai conçu un adjectif maintenant
pour amener les jeunes à aller j'appelle
ça du Sibérie cover la cyber résilience
voilà pour mettre le mot cyber en face
du plus vieux métier du monde de l'Haïti
qui est le backup le plan de reprise
d'activité vous avez l'impression que il
y a un peu plus de prise en compte on
les on l'entendait dans les dans les
propos de la mère de c'est un vide de
ses enjeux cybersécurité aujourd'hui par
exemple on parle des collectivités elles
prennent plus en compte aujourd'hui ces
enjeux mais je leur souhaite je le
souhaite c'était essentiel c'est vital
aujourd'hui si vous avez pas un plan de
backup correct de donc excuse-moi de
sauvegarde j'essaye d'utiliser les mots
appropriés et donc de tester si regarde
à travers un plan d'emprise d'activité
vous ne redémarrez pas parce que de
toute façon quel que soit le budget et
encore une fois je ne je n'oppose pas
sécurité secours donc vous méprenez pas
sur mes propos mais en revanche je dis
une chose si vous ne testez pas vos
processus de secours vous ne
redémarrerez pas vous ne redémarrerez
pas et l'important c'est de redémarrer
même si vous prenez cinq jours même
s'ils prennent 10 jours pour redémarre
c'est de redémarrer le plus important et
c'est ce qu'on offre aujourd'hui c'est
ce qu'on propose dans un modèle de tiers
de confiance parce que c'est trop ça
devient trop complexe et parce que ça
c'est du 7 7 24 24 ça veut dire que
quand on voit par exemple l'incident qui
s'est déroulé à l'hôpital André Mignot
du généraux concours cet enjeu n'avait
pas encore été pris à sa de valeur on va
dire ce qu'on a vu que ça ça perturbait
et il y a encore aujourd'hui des
conséquences Nicolas le disait la prise
en compte quand même des patients il y a
vraiment eu aussi sur l'offre de soins
un manque après suite à cette
cyberattaque c'est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'on propose aujourd'hui à travers bien
évidemment les différents par les
divines numériques voilà il vit
numérique propose de service
aux collectivités locales et aux
hôpitaux bien évidemment de chiffre
d'affaires par exemple vous travaillez
plus quand même avec des entreprises
avec du privé que de la fonction
publique aujourd'hui oui c'est vrai
parce que il faut trouver encore les les
marchés qui permettent d'accès dans ce
type de marché et
voilà il vit numérique a su ouvrir à ce
type de marché elle sait assez innovant
dans cette démarche c'est pas le cas
malheureusement de tous les marchés
publics aujourd'hui d'être innovant dans
cette démarche là et vous avez une
activité qui ne cesse de croître je me
rappelle d'une émission que nous avions
enregistré en 20 vous étiez à 90
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
aujourd'hui vous allez nous annoncer le
chiffre de cette année c'est ça 77 120
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
c'est c'est 300 personnes bien
évidemment c'est tout un tas de
certifications
santé parce que tout ça ça doit
s'accompagner des bonnes démarches des
bonnes pratiques d'accord pour garantir
ce que l'on produit à nos à nos clients
parce que derrière on s'engage moi je
m'engage sur la restauration c'est un
vrai sujet
donc les bonnes pratiques les
compétences et puis essayer de bien
évidemment on est en Yvelines
mais c'est bien évidemment d'embaucher
des collaborateurs de
la région bien sûr et c'est un élément
essentiel on a des très belles
universités une dernière question est-ce
que vous avez l'impression que les
territoires aujourd'hui sont des cibles
plus importantes on va plus les cibler
par rapport à des entreprises que vous
accompagnez vous davantage
je dirais qu'une entreprise ça va pas
forcément dire
voilà parce que vous imaginez par
rapport aux fournisseurs aux clients au
banquier c'est tout de suite finalement
et puis voilà des obligations je dis pas
qu'une entreprise a pas certaines
obligations en fonction de leur taille
mais aujourd'hui c'est vrai que dans une
entreprise ça peut ça peut
potentiellement être tabou voilà parce
que parce que le risque derrière
économique est important alors peut-être
qu'un jour vous fait revenir à propos de
l'assurance risque cyber qui est un
autre qui est un autre sujet enfin qui
est une thématique ici bien évidemment
été essentielle également pour eux mais
on parle quand même d'enjeux qui sont
extrêmement stratégiques aujourd'hui
alors des fois
je pousse le bouchon un peu loin sur sur
cette thématique là mais c'est
volontaire c'est volontaire très
rapidement c'est juste pour conclure
parce que on dit qu'il y a énormément de
cyberattaque mais il y a quand même
beaucoup de cyberata qui sont contrées
et qui n'ont pas eu lieu du coup du fait
notamment de collaborateurs comme chez
anthemeta ou d'autres collaborateur on
pense notamment sur le territoire arabus
cybersécurité ou d'autres startups même
qui sont spécialisés dans ce domaine là
merci en tout cas Stéphane blanc d'être
venu en parler en plein tout je crois
c'est un sujet qui inquiété à côté de
vous Rodriguez tout à l'heure le moins
qui études parce qu'on parle de données
personnelles donc c'est clair que de
savoir que quand on se fait attaquer
comme ça et qu'on peut perdre nos
données est capable de la nature je
trouve ça super inquiétant donc merci
pour le travail ben écoutez je vous
remercie c'est sympa merci pour le vôtre
aussi parce que nos jeunes il faut s'en
occuper et c'est bien pour félicite je
pense qu'on va tomber d'accord voilà
allez c'est le plateau des rencontres
c'est bien ça l'objectif du 7 8 et on va
parler bien sûr dans un instant de la
grosse performance réalisée par les
féminines de Trappes lors de la madewi's
Ligue merci encore d'avoir été avec nous
Stéphane blanc